فاصل بين جولتين انتخابيتين في تركيا لا
مجال فيه للاستراحه بل سيكونان الاسبوعين
الاكثر مشقه لطرفي المنافسه للوصول الى
الاغلبيه المطلوبه للفوز
[تصفيق]
نفس قومي يطغى في تركيا متجليا في نتائج
الانتخابات فبالرغم من تقدم تحالف اردوغان
على المعارضه ذات الطابع القومي الا ان
المحللين ووسائل الاعلام باختلاف توجهاتها
اتفقت على ان الاحزاب القوميه حتى تلك
التي لم تكن ضمن ائتلاف المعارضه استطاعت
ان تترك بصمه واضحه في نتائج الانتخابات
ان احدى النتائج الاكثر لفتا للانتباه في
انتخابات هذا العام هي بلا شك صعود اصوات
القوميين من النتائج المهمه الاخرى
للانتخابات ثقل الناخبين القوميين في
المعادلات السياسيه
اما الخلاف في الاوساط الاعلاميه
والسياسيه في تركيا فهو حول دوري اصوات
سينان اوغان مرشح تحالف الاجداد القومي
والذي حصل على خمسه في المئه من الاصوات
وفي مصلحه اي طرف ستصب تلك الاصوات بعد
خروجه من السباق الانتخابي وان كانت ستغير
شيئا من النتيجه
للتفاوض مع المرشحين الذين ترك للجوله
الثانيه
لا ينبغي لاحد الاعتقاد بان الاصوات
المدلى بها لسنان اجان هي اصوات صلبه
الاخيره يدعو داعم المعارضه الى جذب اصوات
مرشح حزب البلد القومي محرم انجاح الذي
انسحب قبل ايام من الانتخابات بينما يرى
اخرون ان نتيجه محسومه اصلا لصالح اردوغان
طاقه محرم انجي يجب احضارها الى تحالف
الامه اذا كان ذلك ممكنا
اردوغان سيذهب الى الجوله الثانيه بثلاث
مزايا على الاقل هي الاغلبيه في البرلمان
والمركز الاول في انتخابات الرئاسه الاولى
والتقدم الواضح
نقطه واحده تلعب على نتيجه الجوله القادمه
وهي اصوات القوميين المنسحبين من السباق
الانتخابي والذين لا يفضلون ايا من
المرشحين الحاليين ومن جهه اخرى محاوله
اردوغان لكسب اصوات الاكراد في اسطنبول
اذا عمر العربيه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على يوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات